it is these millions of little micro
decisions that we make over and over and
over which either take us further away
from ourselves or bring us closer back
to ourselves
[Music]
erica curtis how are you doing hi thanks
so much for having me i'm excited to be
here
it's it's really wonderful to uh for you
to be here on the show i'm really
excited to talk about
authenticity talking about individuality
through your lenses because
you are a former google business
executive
spent many years there and and you've
taken a different route now
towards understanding a little bit of of
who we are and and what we strive to be
and how to be our authentic selves
so i'm excited to hear from you what
that really means to you
and how you help others achieve that
awesome i'm very excited to talk about
it it's a
topic that is incredibly close to my
heart and certainly
what i have devoted my life to wonderful
so authenticity
talk to me a little bit about what does
authenticity mean
uh so the challenge with authenticity is
it's one of those cliched terms and like
so many of them
in this industry of um self-improvement
or personal development
that we don't really know what it
actually means so the way i define
authenticity
is the practice of letting go of who we
think we need to be and
embracing who we truly are because i
really believe
that when we embrace who we actually
are we're able to have much greater
impact
in on on our communities on our families
and on the world around us so you know
i'm just as
you know as a young entrepreneur myself
and i'm always looking at different
and different startups and different
products and i'm thinking of that now as
a product of how to how to help one
become more authentic
and it starts always with a pain point
right what what is the problem that
you're trying to solve so i'd love to
hear a little bit about your journey
and how you transition from your work in
in the workforce to understanding that
there is a problem
that perhaps people are not as authentic
as they could be
to your point um i was my biggest pain
point
and i experienced this sort of emptiness
inside of me almost all of my life i
called it the void
some people call it like a black hole or
just an emptiness in the pit of their
stomach
and um it's i thought i was alone in
that feeling
and i always i thought that the best way
for me to overcome that experience was
to
do more achieve more be more and so
it led me to basically a lifetime of
collecting gold stars
and doing everything i thought i needed
to do
in order to be the best and in seeking
perfection
i completely lost myself and i
what i really began to realize is that
perfect wasn't even good enough i mean i
and it wasn't just perfect in my job it
was perfect in all parts of my life i
needed to be the perfect wife the
perfect mother the perfect
employee the perfect um homemaker like
all of the things
and in doing so i was putting out so
many fires
i didn't realize i was the one getting
burned over
and over and over again and
the pivot point in my life because um i
think every good
hero's quest has an inciting event and
um
mine was that when my second daughter
was born she was born with a
tumor on her spinal cord which we didn't
know about until she was
uh two weeks old and it required that
she had
a seven hour spinal neurosurgery when
she was three months old
which was so far off of any plan that i
had developed for how my perfectly
curated life was supposed to go
that it really it made me take a deeper
look at my life
um she is okay she will have to have
other surgeries in her life but i'll
skip ahead to that in case i forget
um but while i was in the hospital i had
a thought that changed my life
and the thought was i have one life to
live there are no second chances
no do-overs i get one go-round of this
life why would i spend
one more minute waiting to be happy and
what i realized
is was i was in my my 30s i had already
been at google for
um i don't know nine years at that point
something like that
and i was i didn't feel like i was
living my life i felt like i was living
somebody else's life
and i had to start getting really really
honest with myself about
how and where and why i was going
through the motions
in all parts of my life and start making
changes that enabled me to get back to a
closer
get closer to who i truly am and it's
not something that you make in one
decision
it's uh that's why i call it a practice
because it's
we don't lose ourselves or find
ourselves or make changes with any one
grand decision
it is these millions of little micro
decisions that we make over and over and
over which either take us further away
from ourselves or bring us closer back
to ourselves
and so that's what i teach now is how to
listen more deeply to what's missing
and how we can begin to find it for
ourselves so that we can begin to
embrace who we are what we truly want in
our lives
so what was the most difficult part of
of making that tangible transition so i
understand
that the mindset that you're entering
this and you you sort of you're
accumulating this
inner inner understanding that you're
not necessarily fulfilling
your true potential for happiness and
then there's a trigger in your life
and adversity that triggers it and makes
you realize that okay maybe i should do
something about it but
so how does that actually happen that
transition to do something about it
with a lot of crying um i know i think
the transition requires we have to get
to a place where we realize that
we can't just keep being okay with okay
and i i know
so many high achievers and overachievers
who
uh you know you'll ask how they're doing
they're fine everything's everything's
fine first of all problems i have
nothing to complain about
and when we do that we're really
ignoring some deeper yearning inside of
ourselves that
doesn't do us or the world a service and
talking about how fine everything is yes
it may be first world problems but if we
ignore those things
we could actually if we were to actually
pay attention to those things
we could solve a lot of third world
problems by actually paying attention to
the yearnings in our heart and our souls
and i i believe that each of us has the
capability of changing the world
but we can only do that when we start by
changing ourselves
and so for me that change required
getting really really honest with myself
about
why i was stuck what i was holding on to
and
the iteration for me included first um i
ended up leaving my marriage because i
realized it was never going to be what i
needed it to be
and i had become a such a different
person in order to be married that
uh as i became more myself it just
didn't work anymore
which was on me um and then i started
getting honest with myself that
while i loved google i mean i was a
preeminent google cheerleader i was
always
at google they have um interviews that
are like a googliness interview
which is literally determining how
googly you are um
it was always me like i i can nail
googliness
from a mile away i because i love
google and i consider myself i graduated
from there i didn't leave there because
i really did love it
but i found something that i that for me
i loved
more and that was helping make a
difference in people's lives and so it
was incredibly hard for me to leave
um and it has been the most rewarding
journey and transition i've ever made in
my life also the hardest
right it sounds like a very positive
transition but i i have to
you know grasp because there seems to be
a fine balance between when
this transition happens right because
you know one of the things that happened
as i
as i transitioned into my my college
education and i came into
a university older than most of my peers
i was 24 most of them were 18.
i had commanded previously teams in the
israel defense forces and and when i
came in and people were asking i
remember
the first occurrences i was riding my
bike and somebody was running past me
and they screamed how are you doing and
i and i thought
and then they continued they didn't i
couldn't even have time to respond
and i started seeing this more and more
often that people are asking questions
about how you're doing but they're not
either they're either not waiting for
answers or the answers that they gave me
when i asked them
truthfully they're very they're very um
you know
on the surface and that made me think
about the society sort of and this sort
of the race that you're
that you're describing to become the
perfect self but
on the other hand without striving and
without sometimes doing as we're growing
up things that we don't necessarily
enjoy
we can't get to be an executive at
google
right yeah so how does that work so how
does that balance work and at what point
in your life
do you have to become more authentic
versus just going along with what the
society is telling you
well i think that we are always at a
crossroads at every point in our lives
to make a decision
between um holding on to
good and safe or letting go of that and
going after what is great and true and
authentic for our lives
and most of us never make that choice to
go toward what's great because it
requires
letting go of safety it requires letting
go of certainty requires letting go of
our comfort zone
and walking without any guarantees
straight into the fog of the unknown
and that's incredibly scary um
so you know the er the younger we are
while yes we tend to be more
um risk tolerance to a certain extent
when we're younger
most of us are still um very insecure
with ourselves we're still trying to
figure out who we are just you know
at any level whether it's surface or
deeper um so
for me i don't think it could have
happened earlier i mean there were so
many opportunities before
i actually decided to go down this road
um that i just didn't take those
opportunities because i just wasn't
ready for them
but i also really believe that
everything that we experience
is intended to prepare us for what is to
come so all those previous times where i
chose
good instead of great helped motivate me
because i learned over and over and over
again i choose good
i don't feel good it's comfortable or at
least it's known
but it doesn't feel good it just feels
empty or it feels hollow or it feels
surface as you said
it doesn't feel rich and rewarding and
full
and when i experienced it enough times i
realized
i don't i don't want to live a life that
by the end of my lifetime i look back
and think
that wasn't so bad i want to look back
and have it have been an adventure
know that i really experienced full
range and
full range what i've discovered is i
thought when i started on this
um journey that full arrangement not
being locked into
a marriage or a job that you know was
holding me back or keeping me down
that's not what full range is at all
full range is about being able to feel
everything experience life fully which
means
all the joys and all the fears all the
happiness
and all the pain and when we know that
we can do all of that and we will be
okay
no matter what we're not guarding
ourselves from those experiences
we're throwing ourselves into them and
that's what i hope for everybody because
so many of us
stay on these incredibly narrow paths
just doing the same things over and over
again whether it's in a personal
relationship or professional job
and it's because we're too afraid of
will we be able to actually make it
if we let go of this and go towards
something else and when we start to
realize
we're going to make it no matter what we
are going to be okay
even if it means risking everything
that's when we get to really truly live
and have impact
so you leave the the high intent the
very intensive job that you had at
google and
now you're helping others achieve their
their authentic potential so what does
that actually mean how
what do you do on a day-to-day basis
that is helping others uh
go through a similar journey that you
went through
um i so my favorite thing at google was
building relationships
and deepening connections and
establishing trust uh it's what i was
i've always been really sort of innately
good at
uh and that's exactly what i get to do
all day
every day is listen to people
and hold space for them to um be really
honest and vulnerable i mean there
aren't a lot of people in our lives if
you think about
you know how much of the time do you
feel like you can truly be
vulnerable around somebody it's not very
often and
to be able to give people the space and
the gift of
of allowing them to feel really safe
being vulnerable
is in and of itself a great gift and
when we allow ourselves to be vulnerable
and like expose the fear
and talk about the stuff that we don't
ever want to say out loud to anybody
because we think oh my god what are they
going to think about me they're going to
run for the hills or
um then we start to realize that stuff
is actually just
they're just fear stories they're not
real um
and when we can bring those things to
the surface instead of like
uh ignoring them or denying them or
pretending they don't exist
then they stop having as much power and
when we can
take the power away from those deeper
things that keep us stuck
we're so much more free to take action
and make a bigger impact in our lives
and so
that's what i do is i really help people
identify um
what those some people call them
limiting beliefs i think they're they're
deep they tend to be deeper than
that i call them fear stories um and
most of us don't even know
that you know they're playing out over
and over and over and over in our lives
and over and over again in our micro
decisions right not just in the grass
it's in the day-to-day things the
thousand decisions we make every minute
exactly
right so how do you how do you help
people go through that
that understanding so it sounds like
it's not just you know a nice
a one-hour zoom call okay tell me your
fear stories and let's get and let's get
them out of the way right
it sounds like it sounds like a more
difficult process what is your role in
that process and how does that
how does it how does the life cycle of
this look for for somebody who's working
with you
um it's a great question so i mean you
know it differs i don't have like a
process a set agenda like i i used to be
super process or well relatively process
oriented
um very planned and structured in my
work at google
and now i go into every call completely
unprepared because i know i'm actually
prepared no matter what i can handle
whatever is going to come
and um so what i always say to every
client is
i it doesn't there's no topic that's off
the table because
the thing is no matter what topic we're
talking about it's all the
door different doors into the same
deeper stuff and so
we don't realize it but we're playing
out the same patterns
in our personal lives and our
professional lives and our family lives
and
you know all these places and so what
the way it typically looks
is that especially for like i'll give
you an executive for as an example
um an executive i'm working with is
talking about how she
is um launching a a new business plan
to her organization and we start talking
about what's holding her back
from actually taking action or how she's
procrastinating on writing the email
or how she's looking you know and all of
that stuff you know there's the surface
power through it and just get past it
right and then there's the deeper stuff
of why does this keep happening
what is it that we're actually butting
up against because what we tend to look
at
as human beings especially in the
workforce um
when we want to make a change we look at
the tactical things that we need to do
differently well
you know what are the new skills what
are the new habits i need to develop
and that's great but that's actually
only about 20 of the issue
the other 80 is the mindset that keeps
us
stuck in those habits and doing those
things in the same way we're doing them
and so if we don't look at the mindset
that is causing the behavior
then you'll just see it repeating itself
over and over again
and so when we go into the mindset and
look at well what's
you know what's yucky about that like
what's the most dangerous thing about
sending an email that's not
you know totally fleshed out or that you
may not have vetted with 10 people or
whatever
what we tend to come up with is well
people will think i look stupid okay
what's bad about looking stupid
well if i look stupid then people will
think i'm a failure they won't trust me
so when we get down to these deeper
levels it is always about an identity
that we think we need to hold on to
some way that we believe we need to show
up in this world
that we are so deeply attached to and if
we don't show up this way
then we risk no longer belonging we risk
our worthiness
and so when we can detach ourselves
from that fear story then it becomes so
much better like okay great so i sent an
email that
you know maybe not everybody loved and
some people might disagree with it but
it doesn't it doesn't impact my
worthiness right
it just impacts this one thing right now
and i'm sure that there
that so many people who will be watching
this are can resonate
you know either on the micro level or
the macro level with the things that
you're describing here
what are some tangible things that you
know the average person can do to help
get over these
these fears or at least try to to
embrace them and understand that they
exist
yeah um so what i always encourage
anybody whether you're
we all have well most most of us have
goals things that we want to accomplish
whether it's losing weight or it's
taking on a new role or it's
um you know just making more time for
yourself or creating more balance in
your work schedule
so whatever the goal is think about that
goal and then ask yourself what are the
things i'm doing
that do not support me actually
accomplishing that goal so for instance
i'll say
balance work schedule most of us
overachievers tend to like
you know create a lot more time on our
work than we do
you know making time for our families
well what am i not doing well i'm
checking email first thing in the
morning i am
emailing people back on the weekends i'm
sending emails late i'm working on the
i'm working on decks in the weekend
whatever
all of those things are then we have to
start asking ourselves
what if i didn't do any of that stuff
what would that make me feel
how would i feel about that if i just
stopped if i actually just
did what i wanted to do and actually
just created balance what is yucky about
that actual feeling
and what we tend to realize is oh well i
have to do that because what would
people think if i didn't reply back to
them they might think that i'm
ignoring them or they might think that
i'm not trustworthy or they might
question my
ability to do the work or whatever it is
and again um as we get to those deeper
layers we start to see some of the
the identity related things
and when we start to see what those
identity related fears are
then we start to see how that's keeping
us really stuck
and so it's always like asking yourself
what is yucky about or or um
scary or uncomfortable about
dropping all of the things i'm doing
that keep me safe
definitely are there some higher level
trends that we are that we're observing
as the workforce is dramatically
changing and obviously things are
becoming
and more and more competitive as the
time goes by i believe that the most
recently
uh the at least in in silicon valley the
the number of years that somebody spends
in a tech company is about two three
years
which i think just adds on to the stress
levels of continuously to
to improve and to gain to new heights
even though it's not something that we
might
be actually passionate about are there
some higher level trends that we that
you're observing or that we should be
worried about or optimistic about
well what i am observing to your i'll
speak specifically to what you just
mentioned
um is this idea that we need to keep
trading up and things will get better as
we trade
um like for instance a lot of people
that i worked with at google left google
to go to competitors thinking it's going
to be better they had been at google for
a long time it's going to be better when
i go to this new place
and it didn't get better it was the same
thing with slightly different scenery
and um and that's what people find over
and over again it doesn't matter
you know whether you're in tech or in
other companies and so
when when we realize that the change
doesn't come from the outside
that really is an invitation for us to
go inside and again shift our mindset
because
the scenery is just may look a little
bit different but it's going to feel the
same way as long as we keep those same
mindsets
and i just think it's getting it's
becoming more obvious
and i think people are starting to
recognize some of their
limiting habits and patterns especially
because we have this
pressure cooker of being at home and
zoom and all the other stuff that's
happening in the world right now
definitely definitely erica i want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time
and this was wonderful and before we
leave i have to ask you for three words
that you would use to describe yourself
okay
i would say energetic energetic
probably really really energetic um
let's see divergent and
why divergent um
so i i call it divergent because i used
to think that like i needed to ignore
the parts of me that didn't really fit
in
with the mold and the more that i
realized that
especially there are so many people that
are high achievers and really
intelligent people that think
well this part of me doesn't really make
sense with the rest of me
and so many of us when we give ourselves
to actually give ourselves permission to
be
our full selves we are way cooler people
and so i say i'm divergent because i
um like i'm highly spiritual and i have
a very perverted sense of humor
i used to think those two things could
not work together but they very much
do because they they're part of me or
you know i like i love intense workouts
and my favorite thing to do is sit
outside and do nothing all day um
so yeah i just i'm very divergent um and
the third would be
passionate i love it okay erica thank
you so so much
this was insightful and and wonderful
and and best of luck on the journey and
thank you for thank you for being very
open and honest about your own journey
yeah thank you so much for having me i'm
really really thrilled to have been here
best of luck to you as well take care